syfy jambes holloway est le meilleur de
l'histoire les arts de l'histoire
donc tout le monde croit jean paul que
vous avez inventé ça comme ça au dernier
moment au micro pour dégeler
l'atmosphère mais pas du tout c'était
c'était poule woerth qui avait demandé à
la petite depardieu de vous toucher
l'écho exactement parce qu'on on à
tourner dans le même film podium et
julie fait la femme de benoît et à lui
comme s'il savait que les remèdes à leur
mettez le césar j'ai l'espoir lui a dit
si jamais c'est jean paul tu touches le
courrier laval delà de la robe est prévu
cette vanne d'entrée et évidemment il ya
les couilles avant et c'est à planter sa
a planté la graine de l'arop j'aime
frégère frais la prochaine pour un 7
d'or ou à mollir a commencé ça fait quoi
d'être enfin je vais pas dire meilleurs
jeunes espoirs mes meilleurs espoirs du
cinéma français
ben ouais ça fait plaisir à un régime
par plaisir et se faire plaisir
super plaisir plaisir vous valez bien
gérée dakar eh ben c'est bien plaisir au
charisme c'était grand plaisir tu cap
est un peu non a dit ça